This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWO percent。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和而言是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.|||请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他获取播客的平台收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都并不真正安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并订阅《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces|||2023年，《钻石单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你篡改过这份特定的测试报告两次，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批网络侦探出动，才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to firstly, just before we get into it, thank you all for the love that you have been showing my book recently. If you didn't know, I released a book early this year.
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to firstly, just before we get into it, thank you all for the love that you have been showing my book recently. If you didn't know, I released a book early this year.|||后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎新老听众回到这个播客，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析20多岁的心理学。在深入正题之前，我想首先感谢大家最近对我的书给予的喜爱。如果你还不知道的话，我今年早些时候出版了一本书。
It's called Person in Progress. And in the last month, I have just been receiving some of the kindest reviews, kindest comments, kindest messages from you all out of nowhere. So I just wanted to give you a formal thank you for just being so kind about this thing that I put out into the world. If you are yet to get your hands on a copy, the book is basically, well like the ultimate and extended guide to the psychology of your 20s. So if you like the podcast, I think I can make a fairly certain assumption that you will like the book as well. I will leave
It's called Person in Progress. And in the last month, I have just been receiving some of the kindest reviews, kindest comments, kindest messages from you all out of nowhere. So I just wanted to give you a formal thank you for just being so kind about this thing that I put out into the world. If you are yet to get your hands on a copy, the book is basically, well like the ultimate and extended guide to the psychology of your 20s. So if you like the podcast, I think I can make a fairly certain assumption that you will like the book as well. I will leave|||它叫《Person in Progress》（成长中的人）。在过去的一个月里，我突然收到了来自你们的各种极其温暖的评价、评论和私信。所以我只想正式感谢大家，感谢你们对我带到这个世界上的作品报以如此大的善意。如果你还没买到这本书，它基本上就是——嗯，就像是关于20多岁心理学的终极加长版指南。所以如果你喜欢这个播客，我想我可以相当确信地假设你也会喜欢这本书。我会留一个
a link in the description. But again, you have all of my gratitude. Thank you so much to you all. So for today, I can't speak for you guys. But recently I have been going through, I would say a few periods of feeling very alien, very unlike myself. It's been this strange experience where the best way I can summarize it is that people will ask me, you know, describe yourself or they'll ask me what I'm interested in or who I am beyond work or beyond my immediate relationships. And I'm kind of in this situation of grasping at straws at the moment, interest, values, hobbies. Like I know I have them, but there's this strange war between me and the things that
a link in the description. But again, you have all of my gratitude. Thank you so much to you all. So for today, I can't speak for you guys. But recently I have been going through, I would say a few periods of feeling very alien, very unlike myself. It's been this strange experience where the best way I can summarize it is that people will ask me, you know, describe yourself or they'll ask me what I'm interested in or who I am beyond work or beyond my immediate relationships. And I'm kind of in this situation of grasping at straws at the moment, interest, values, hobbies. Like I know I have them, but there's this strange war between me and the things that|||链接在简介里。但再次感谢大家，向你们致以我全部的谢意。非常感谢大家。那么今天，我不能代表你们大家。但最近我一直在经历，我可以说是有过好几次觉得自己非常陌生、非常不像自己的时期。这是一种奇怪的体验，我能总结出的最好方式就是，人们会问我，你知道的，描述一下你自己，或者他们会问我除了工作或直接的人际关系之外，我对什么感兴趣，或者我是谁。目前我处于一种绞尽脑汁、毫无头绪的境遇中，兴趣、价值观、爱好。就像我知道我有这些东西，但在我和那些
make me me that means that I feel kind of strange and unoriginal and a little bit bland and very detached from myself. I remember this period right after my last boyfriend and I broke up where I felt very similar. You know, that relationship rocked my confidence so much that for like six months afterwards, I just felt like I was living outside of my body in a way and all the things I knew to be true about the person I was felt impossible to feel. I also had moved cities at the time and was trying to make new friends and I just felt so detached from my spirit. I couldn't hold a conversation. I couldn't really engage with people on a deep level. It seems like this detachment is the best word. This detachment from our sense of self is a fairly common experience for a lot of us in our 20s.
make me me that means that I feel kind of strange and unoriginal and a little bit bland and very detached from myself. I remember this period right after my last boyfriend and I broke up where I felt very similar. You know, that relationship rocked my confidence so much that for like six months afterwards, I just felt like I was living outside of my body in a way and all the things I knew to be true about the person I was felt impossible to feel. I also had moved cities at the time and was trying to make new friends and I just felt so detached from my spirit. I couldn't hold a conversation. I couldn't really engage with people on a deep level. It seems like this detachment is the best word. This detachment from our sense of self is a fairly common experience for a lot of us in our 20s.|||让我成为“我”的事物之间，存在着一种奇怪的战争，这意味着我感到有点奇怪、毫无新意、有点乏味，而且与自我非常脱节。我记得就在我和前男友分手后的那段时间里，我也有过非常相似的感觉。你知道，那段感情极大地动摇了我的自信，以至于在接下来的大约六个月里，我感觉自己就像是灵魂出窍了一样，所有我自认为真实的关于我自己的事情，都变得无法感知。当时我还搬了城市，试图结交新朋友，我只是觉得与自己的精神世界严重脱节。我无法进行对话。我无法真正与人进行深层次的交流。这种“脱节”似乎是最好的词。这种与自我意识的脱节对于我们许多人在20多岁时来说是一次相当普遍的经历。
think actually it occurs in quite a cyclical manner. We go through periods of feeling very confident, feeling very alive, and then suddenly out of nowhere, we just don't feel like ourselves anymore. And it kind of serves as a reminder of when we need to reconnect with the deeper parts of ourselves, when we need to re-identify what we care about. But it's also kind of a really scary and uncomfortable feeling. So today I want to dissect and kind of break down that feeling. I want to give you as well a bit of a guide as to how we can feel like ourselves again or how we can perhaps connect with a newer version of ourselves that's emerging when we are feeling kind of like a stranger in our own life and a stranger in our own body. We are also not just going to talk
think actually it occurs in quite a cyclical manner. We go through periods of feeling very confident, feeling very alive, and then suddenly out of nowhere, we just don't feel like ourselves anymore. And it kind of serves as a reminder of when we need to reconnect with the deeper parts of ourselves, when we need to re-identify what we care about. But it's also kind of a really scary and uncomfortable feeling. So today I want to dissect and kind of break down that feeling. I want to give you as well a bit of a guide as to how we can feel like ourselves again or how we can perhaps connect with a newer version of ourselves that's emerging when we are feeling kind of like a stranger in our own life and a stranger in our own body. We are also not just going to talk|||我认为实际上它以相当周期性的方式发生。我们经历过感觉非常自信、充满生机的时期，然后突然之间，我们就不再像自己了。这就像是一个提醒，提醒我们需要重新与内心的更深处建立联系，重新明确我们在乎的是什么。但这同时也是一种非常可怕和不舒服的感觉。所以今天我想剖析并分解这种感觉。我也想为你提供一份指南，告诉你我们如何才能重新找回自我，或者当我们感觉自己就像生活中的陌生人、自己身体里的陌生人时，如何与正在萌芽的更新版本的自己建立联系。我们不仅仅要谈论
about things that are run of the mill. Journaling, meditation, spending time doing your hobbies are all fabulous, fabulous ways to combat, not feeling like yourself. But feel like we all kind of know them. I want to just go a little bit deeper and a little bit broader and give you some tips and advice that you probably haven't heard before, some research that you probably haven't heard before so that this episode is as practical, informative and as original as it can be so that it is as helpful as it can be as well. We're also going to talk about why you may be experiencing this at this chapter or point in your life, but also why it's maybe not a bad thing to feel a little bit lost within yourself sometimes. So without further ado, we have so
about things that are run of the mill. Journaling, meditation, spending time doing your hobbies are all fabulous, fabulous ways to combat, not feeling like yourself. But feel like we all kind of know them. I want to just go a little bit deeper and a little bit broader and give you some tips and advice that you probably haven't heard before, some research that you probably haven't heard before so that this episode is as practical, informative and as original as it can be so that it is as helpful as it can be as well. We're also going to talk about why you may be experiencing this at this chapter or point in your life, but also why it's maybe not a bad thing to feel a little bit lost within yourself sometimes. So without further ado, we have so|||那些陈词滥调。写日记、冥想、花时间做你的爱好，这些都是对抗“不像自己”的绝妙绝妙的方法。但感觉我们大家都差不多知道这些。我想更深入、更广泛地探讨一下，给你一些你可能从未听过的技巧和建议，一些你可能从未听过的研究，以便让这一集尽可能实用、信息丰富且富有创意，从而使其尽可能地有帮助。我们还将会谈到为什么你可能会在生活中的这个阶段或时间点经历这种感觉，以及为什么有时候在内心感到有点迷茫可能并非一件坏事。所以废话不多说，我们有
much to cover. So let's get into my guide to how to feel like yourself again. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
much to cover. So let's get into my guide to how to feel like yourself again. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.|||太多内容要讲了。让我们进入关于如何找回自我的指南吧。2%.这就是在有自动扶梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?|||我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWO% 的播客。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）胸部的那个场景吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence.|||其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备有一天聊聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了台面上，所以。谢谢你帮我把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,|||是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他获取播客的平台收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。借着心理健康意识月的契机，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.|||我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗?因为这是两个不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.|||绝对是这样。这也是两种不同信任层面的体现。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，我是科尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真正的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《钻石单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了她言辞中显而易见的不一致之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.|||由此开启了一场历时多年的法庭之争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你篡改过这份特定的测试报告两次，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批网络侦探出动，才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is|||格雷格·阿莱斯皮安、迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，消息称劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在正义得以伸张之前，这一切都不会结束
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Before we get into the seven plus strategies I have for you today, let me just say the best thing you can do before you implement any new habits before you try any 30-day reset, any 75 hard program, anything like that, basically before you add anything to your already busy life, it's just to understand why this disconnect may be occurring. There is no growth without self-knowledge. And the thing is, this feeling probably isn't an accident. it is stemming from somewhere, something in your life that is creating dissatisfaction or disconnect.
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Before we get into the seven plus strategies I have for you today, let me just say the best thing you can do before you implement any new habits before you try any 30-day reset, any 75 hard program, anything like that, basically before you add anything to your already busy life, it's just to understand why this disconnect may be occurring. There is no growth without self-knowledge. And the thing is, this feeling probably isn't an accident. it is stemming from somewhere, something in your life that is creating dissatisfaction or disconnect.|||在亚利桑那州。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。在我们探讨我今天为你准备的七个以上策略之前，请容许我先说一句：在你实施任何新习惯之前，在你尝试任何30天重置、任何“75硬核”计划或类似的事情之前——基本上，在你往本已忙碌的生活中添加任何东西之前——你能做的最好的事情，就是去理解这种脱节感为什么会发生。没有自我认知，就没有成长。而且关键在于，这种感觉很可能不是偶然的。它源于某个地方，源于你生活中某种正在制造不满或脱节的事物。
The most likely explanations are as follows. Firstly, you may be feeling unlike yourself because you've just become a little bit stuck. You are in a period of stagnation where nothing feels new, nothing feels different. Your days are the same. Your routines are the same. And as a result, your sense of... of self, your soul, whatever you want to label it, this core part of who you are is not being given the opportunity to expand. The thing is, our sense of self is not a static thing. It demands constant
The most likely explanations are as follows. Firstly, you may be feeling unlike yourself because you've just become a little bit stuck. You are in a period of stagnation where nothing feels new, nothing feels different. Your days are the same. Your routines are the same. And as a result, your sense of... of self, your soul, whatever you want to label it, this core part of who you are is not being given the opportunity to expand. The thing is, our sense of self is not a static thing. It demands constant|||最可能的解释如下。首先，你可能会觉得自己不像自己，因为你只是有点陷入困境了。你正处于一个停滞期，在这个时期，没有什么感觉是新鲜的，没有什么感觉是不同的。你的日子都一样。你的日常生活也一样。结果就是，你的自我意识，你的灵魂，无论你想给它贴上什么标签，你身上的这核心部分都没有得到扩展的机会。关键是，我们的自我意识不是一成不变的东西。它需要不断地
evolution from us. Your sense of self and it's going to sound so silly, like the way I like to describe it, it's kind of like a dolphin. It's kind of like a shark. You know, the moment a dolphin or a shark stops swimming or stops moving forward. You might know this, but they die. And it's kind of similar for your soul. The moment your soul feels like it's not moving forward. It's not experiencing new things. It's not being allowed to grow.
evolution from us. Your sense of self and it's going to sound so silly, like the way I like to describe it, it's kind of like a dolphin. It's kind of like a shark. You know, the moment a dolphin or a shark stops swimming or stops moving forward. You might know this, but they die. And it's kind of similar for your soul. The moment your soul feels like it's not moving forward. It's not experiencing new things. It's not being allowed to grow.|||向我们进化。你的自我意识——这听起来可能会很蠢，就像我喜欢描述的那样——它有点像海豚。它有点像鲨鱼。你知道的，海豚或鲨鱼停止游泳或停止前进的那一刻。你可能知道这一点，它们会死。你的灵魂也是如此。当你的灵魂觉得它没有前进时。它没有经历新事物。它不允许自己成长。
It also kind of experiences a similar kind of death. Psychologically, we thrive when we have a sense of forward motion. This is what the psychologist, Abraham Maslow, you might know him, called self-actualization. So Maslow, I don't want to say created. Maslow, he founded, not even a worse word to use. Basically, he's most famous for his hierarchy of needs. And this idea that the very top need that we want to achieve
It also kind of experiences a similar kind of death. Psychologically, we thrive when we have a sense of forward motion. This is what the psychologist, Abraham Maslow, you might know him, called self-actualization. So Maslow, I don't want to say created. Maslow, he founded, not even a worse word to use. Basically, he's most famous for his hierarchy of needs. And this idea that the very top need that we want to achieve|||它也会经历一种类似死亡的过程。从心理学上讲，当我们有向前运动的感觉时，我们会蓬勃发展。这就是心理学家亚伯拉罕·马斯洛（你可能认识他）所说的自我实现。所以马斯洛——我不想说创造。马斯洛，他创立了——甚至不是一个更好的词来形容。基本上，他最著名的就是他的需求层次理论。以及这样一种观点，即我们想要实现的最高需求
is a state of knowing ourselves and a state of challenging ourselves. That is self-actualization. But he was not the first person to understand this or recognize this. In fact, this core part of human psychology has been understood and practiced by indigenous cultures long before Western psychologists gave it a name. Particularly, Maslow really identified self-actualization as a core priority of the self when he was living with members of the Blackfoot Nation in Canada and in America during the 1930s. And he saw that this community really kind of understood that if a human was to thrive and was to flourish, they needed a sense of movement, of purpose, they needed to be doing things. I think it's really important to talk about where these concepts in Western and modern
is a state of knowing ourselves and a state of challenging ourselves. That is self-actualization. But he was not the first person to understand this or recognize this. In fact, this core part of human psychology has been understood and practiced by indigenous cultures long before Western psychologists gave it a name. Particularly, Maslow really identified self-actualization as a core priority of the self when he was living with members of the Blackfoot Nation in Canada and in America during the 1930s. And he saw that this community really kind of understood that if a human was to thrive and was to flourish, they needed a sense of movement, of purpose, they needed to be doing things. I think it's really important to talk about where these concepts in Western and modern|||是一种了解自我和挑战自我的状态。这就是自我实现。但他并不是第一个理解或认识到这一点的人。事实上，早在西方心理学家给它命名之前很久，人类心理学的这一核心部分就已经被土著文化所理解和践行。特别是，在20世纪30年代生活在加拿大和美国的黑足族（Blackfoot Nation）成员中时，马斯洛真正将自我实现确定为自我的核心优先事项。他看到这个社区真正理解到，如果一个人想要繁荣昌盛，他们就需要有运动感、目标感，他们需要做事情。我认为探讨西方和现代心理学中这些概念的来源是非常重要的
psychology come from way back when and at their roots, because that is a part of history that is often missed. And it's a part of history that I actually didn't know when it comes to self-exualization and the hierarchy of needs until one of the listeners told me. So very interesting that this idea of forward movement is one that cultures and societies have had longer than we as a modern society could put a name to it. So back to what we're talking about. If you have found yourself stuck in a routine, doing very monotonous things, finding that
psychology come from way back when and at their roots, because that is a part of history that is often missed. And it's a part of history that I actually didn't know when it comes to self-exualization and the hierarchy of needs until one of the listeners told me. So very interesting that this idea of forward movement is one that cultures and societies have had longer than we as a modern society could put a name to it. So back to what we're talking about. If you have found yourself stuck in a routine, doing very monotonous things, finding that|||可以追溯到很久以前及其根源，因为那是历史中经常被遗漏的一部分。这也是我实际上并不知道的一段历史，直到一位听众告诉我，我才了解自我实现和需求层次理论的这一部分。所以非常有趣的是，这种向前运动的想法在文化和社会中存在的历史，比我们作为一个现代社会为它命名的时间还要长。所以回到我们正在讨论的话题。如果你发现自己陷入了日复一日的惯例中，做着非常单调的事情，发现
you've outgrown your environment without realizing it, this may be contributing to a deeper detachment from core parts of you. It could also be that you've kind of been stuck in survival mode for longer than you realize. you may be so focused on prioritizing the busy and urgent parts of your life that there hasn't been much room to slow down and to observe and to learn. If this is the case, you know, no wonder you feel disconnected. It's almost impossible for your brain and your body and your mind to pursue growth and expansion when your nervous system has been hijacked by stress, by burnout, by anxiety, maybe even by
you've outgrown your environment without realizing it, this may be contributing to a deeper detachment from core parts of you. It could also be that you've kind of been stuck in survival mode for longer than you realize. you may be so focused on prioritizing the busy and urgent parts of your life that there hasn't been much room to slow down and to observe and to learn. If this is the case, you know, no wonder you feel disconnected. It's almost impossible for your brain and your body and your mind to pursue growth and expansion when your nervous system has been hijacked by stress, by burnout, by anxiety, maybe even by|||你在不知不觉中已经超越了你的环境，这可能会导致你与自己的核心部分产生更深的脱节。这也可能是因为你陷入生存模式的时间比你意识到的要长。你可能太专注于优先处理生活中忙碌和紧迫的部分，以至于没有太多空间慢下来、去观察和学习。如果是这样的话，你知道的，难怪你会感到脱节。当你的神经系统被压力、精疲力竭、焦虑，甚至可能是由……劫持时，你的大脑、身体和心智几乎不可能去追求成长和扩展。
trauma. Additionally, you know, another very valid explanation is that you're just straight up overwhelmed by the state of the world and the state of the news and the tragedy of life at the moment. And because of that, that doesn't feel like there's much worth in prioritizing yourself or your well-being when everything else is falling apart and millions of other people are suffering. It's a very difficult line to cross. You want to be empathetic, but I also beg you not to fall into this trap as awful as the world feels of not taking care of yourself. It's not selfish to take care of yourself and to feel a connection to the deeper parts of you. It's actually incredibly crucial. Just as a little side note to mention that. Secondly, our second explanation for
trauma. Additionally, you know, another very valid explanation is that you're just straight up overwhelmed by the state of the world and the state of the news and the tragedy of life at the moment. And because of that, that doesn't feel like there's much worth in prioritizing yourself or your well-being when everything else is falling apart and millions of other people are suffering. It's a very difficult line to cross. You want to be empathetic, but I also beg you not to fall into this trap as awful as the world feels of not taking care of yourself. It's not selfish to take care of yourself and to feel a connection to the deeper parts of you. It's actually incredibly crucial. Just as a little side note to mention that. Secondly, our second explanation for|||创伤所劫持。此外，你知道的，另一个非常合理的解释是，你只是完全被目前的世界状态、新闻状态和生活悲剧压垮了。正因为如此，当其他一切都在崩溃、数百万人都在受苦时，优先考虑自己或自己的福祉似乎没有什么价值。这是一条很难跨越的界限。你想富有同情心，但我也恳求你不要陷入这个陷阱——无论世界感觉多么糟糕——不要不照顾自己。照顾自己并感受到与内心深处部分的联系并不是自私的。这实际上极其重要。作为一个小插曲顺便提一下。其次，我们的第二个解释是关于
why we may be feeling a little bit lost from ourselves is that we're just bored. Not only are we stuck, we're bored. And so therefore, we're not very interested in the world. and we're not very interested in our own development. Now, this boredom and this apathy can sometimes take years to take a hold, and you don't really realize how just simply uninterested in life you are until you have a moment perhaps like the one you're having right now where you realize like, hey, I don't even know what it means to feel like myself anymore. I don't even know who I am.
why we may be feeling a little bit lost from ourselves is that we're just bored. Not only are we stuck, we're bored. And so therefore, we're not very interested in the world. and we're not very interested in our own development. Now, this boredom and this apathy can sometimes take years to take a hold, and you don't really realize how just simply uninterested in life you are until you have a moment perhaps like the one you're having right now where you realize like, hey, I don't even know what it means to feel like myself anymore. I don't even know who I am.|||为什么我们会觉得自己有点迷失自我，原因在于我们只是感到无聊。我们不仅陷入困境，而且感到无聊。因此，我们对世界不是很感兴趣。我们对自己的发展也不是很感兴趣。现在，这种无聊和冷漠有时可能需要数年时间才会占据主导地位，你甚至不会真正意识到自己对生活是多么的不感兴趣，直到你遇到一个时刻——也许就像你现在经历的这个时刻——你意识到：“嘿，我甚至不知道感觉到自己意味着什么了。我甚至不知道我是谁。”
If someone asked me, I wouldn't know how to answer. this also of course has a bit of a clinical name we know it as depression feeling like you don't know yourself feeling uninterested in life feeling unmotivated is a large sign symptom criteria for a diagnosis with either a minor or a major depressive episode if that's the case yes you will still get something out of this podcast but you'll probably get more out of seeing a therapist who can really, you know, get to the core of your own individual issues. So I would encourage you to see that out as well. The final explanation has to do with you are not living a life in line with your values.
If someone asked me, I wouldn't know how to answer. this also of course has a bit of a clinical name we know it as depression feeling like you don't know yourself feeling uninterested in life feeling unmotivated is a large sign symptom criteria for a diagnosis with either a minor or a major depressive episode if that's the case yes you will still get something out of this podcast but you'll probably get more out of seeing a therapist who can really, you know, get to the core of your own individual issues. So I would encourage you to see that out as well. The final explanation has to do with you are not living a life in line with your values.|||如果有人问我，我都不知道该怎么回答。这当然也有一个临床名称，我们称之为抑郁症。感觉不了解自己、对生活不感兴趣、缺乏动力，这是诊断轻度或重度抑郁发作的主要症状标准。如果是这种情况，是的，你仍然会从这个播客中有所收获，但如果你去看心理治疗师，可能会收获更多，他们真的可以，你知道的，切中你个人问题的核心。所以我也会鼓励你寻求这方面的帮助。最后的解释与你没有过上符合你价值观的生活有关。
That is why you don't feel like yourself. This matters so much more than we think. Our values, although we probably, I don't know about you, I don't think about them day to day, they are still there and they are my compass. And if we throw out the compass, if we ignore the compass, we're obviously going to get very, very lost. If you really value creativity and curiosity, and yet you're doing something in your life that is very systems-based or you're working a job that doesn't really allow you to express yourself and you don't have an outlet elsewhere, you're not going to feel like yourself, are you?
That is why you don't feel like yourself. This matters so much more than we think. Our values, although we probably, I don't know about you, I don't think about them day to day, they are still there and they are my compass. And if we throw out the compass, if we ignore the compass, we're obviously going to get very, very lost. If you really value creativity and curiosity, and yet you're doing something in your life that is very systems-based or you're working a job that doesn't really allow you to express yourself and you don't have an outlet elsewhere, you're not going to feel like yourself, are you?|||这就是为什么你感觉不到自己。这一点比我们想象的要重要得多。我们的价值观，虽然我们可能——我不知道你怎么样，我不会天天去想它们——但它们依然存在，它们是我的指南针。如果我们扔掉指南针，如果我们忽视指南针，我们显然会迷失得非常非常彻底。如果你真的很看重创造力和好奇心，然而你在生活中却在做一些非常死板的事情，或者你正在做一份并不能真正让你表达自我、且在其他地方又没有宣泄口的工作，你不会觉得自己像自己，对吧？
If you value the outdoors and you value adventure and, you know, it's been a while since you've hit the road. Same thing. How I explain this is like taking an animal out of their natural habitat and expecting them to thrive. Taking a human away from their values and expecting them to feel like themselves. It never works. And when you take yourself out of environments or situations that reflect your values, when you don't have opportunity to live your values, you are not going to feel amazing psychologically or mentally, emotionally, even physically.
If you value the outdoors and you value adventure and, you know, it's been a while since you've hit the road. Same thing. How I explain this is like taking an animal out of their natural habitat and expecting them to thrive. Taking a human away from their values and expecting them to feel like themselves. It never works. And when you take yourself out of environments or situations that reflect your values, when you don't have opportunity to live your values, you are not going to feel amazing psychologically or mentally, emotionally, even physically.|||如果你珍视户外活动，珍视冒险，而且，你知道的，你已经很久没有踏上旅程了。同样的道理。我是这样解释的：就像把一只动物带离它们的自然栖息地，却期望它们能茁壮成长一样。把一个人带离他们的价值观，却期望他们能找到自我。这永远行不通。当你把自己带离那些反映你价值观的环境或处境时，当你没有机会践行你的价值观时，你在心理、精神、情感甚至身体上都不会感觉好极了。
So these are the three major explanations for this feeling. Regardless of which one you relate to more, maybe relate to all of them, the path back to yourself really involves a simple process of, A, remembering what you care about, B, remembering what you like about yourself and what you like about being alive and see finding ways to practice that as much as you possibly can so that the gap between you and your truest, purest, highest self gets smaller and smaller. Let's talk about how to do that exactly. I will say some of these strategies may sound a little bit woo-woo, a little bit, you know, in life. but I promise you they work. I promise you there is science behind that. And also,
So these are the three major explanations for this feeling. Regardless of which one you relate to more, maybe relate to all of them, the path back to yourself really involves a simple process of, A, remembering what you care about, B, remembering what you like about yourself and what you like about being alive and see finding ways to practice that as much as you possibly can so that the gap between you and your truest, purest, highest self gets smaller and smaller. Let's talk about how to do that exactly. I will say some of these strategies may sound a little bit woo-woo, a little bit, you know, in life. but I promise you they work. I promise you there is science behind that. And also,|||所以这就是导致这种感觉的三大主要解释。无论你对哪一个更有共鸣，也许对所有这些都有共鸣，通往自我的道路实际上包括一个简单的过程：A，记住你在乎什么；B，记住你喜欢自己的什么以及你喜欢活着的什么；C，尽可能多地寻找方法来践行这些，以便你与最真实、最纯粹、最高的自我之间的差距越来越小。让我们来谈谈具体该怎么做。我想说，其中一些策略听起来可能有点玄乎，有点，你知道的，不够接地气。但我向你保证它们管用。我向你保证这背后是有科学依据的。而且，
what do you have to lose? You know, if you're feeling very lost, I don't think it can get worse than that. And here's a hard truth. You know, if you're at a point of wanting to change, well, that's not just going to happen by thinking about it. You've got to try things that you haven't tried before. And you have to try things that maybe you don't think that will work and be surprised. we're going to start with this first exercise. If you want to feel like yourself again, you have got to identify even just loosely what you mean when you say yourself. Who are you? What does that look like? What does that feel like? What does that version of you behave like? You have to perform a bit of a identity re-evaluation. There's actually heaps of ways to do this. You're in luck.
what do you have to lose? You know, if you're feeling very lost, I don't think it can get worse than that. And here's a hard truth. You know, if you're at a point of wanting to change, well, that's not just going to happen by thinking about it. You've got to try things that you haven't tried before. And you have to try things that maybe you don't think that will work and be surprised. we're going to start with this first exercise. If you want to feel like yourself again, you have got to identify even just loosely what you mean when you say yourself. Who are you? What does that look like? What does that feel like? What does that version of you behave like? You have to perform a bit of a identity re-evaluation. There's actually heaps of ways to do this. You're in luck.|||你有什么好失去的呢？你知道的，如果你感到非常迷茫，我认为情况不会比这更糟了。这里有一个残酷的真相。你知道的，如果你正处于想要改变的时刻，好吧，这不会仅仅通过思考就能发生。你必须尝试一些你以前没有尝试过的事情。你必须尝试一些你可能认为行不通的事情，并准备好感到惊讶。我们将从第一个练习开始。如果你想重新找回自我，你必须大致明确当你提到“自己”时究竟是什么意思。你是谁？那是什么样子的？那是什么感觉？那个版本的你会有什么样的行为？你必须进行一番自我身份的重新评估。其实有很多方法可以做到这一点。你很幸运。
And it's not as hard as it sounds, but the best exercise that I found to do this is something that I call the identity inventory. And it basically just asks you to really just put a spotlight on yourself for a second in a way that you're not used to. Sit down and write out 10 phrases, 10 words that reflect different parts of your identity. Do an inventory. These can be formal roles. So you could say, of my 10 words, I am a teacher, I am a student, I am a mother, whatever. Personal traits, I'm an optimist, I'm an introvert, passions, I love nature, I'm a rider, or it could be relational roles,
And it's not as hard as it sounds, but the best exercise that I found to do this is something that I call the identity inventory. And it basically just asks you to really just put a spotlight on yourself for a second in a way that you're not used to. Sit down and write out 10 phrases, 10 words that reflect different parts of your identity. Do an inventory. These can be formal roles. So you could say, of my 10 words, I am a teacher, I am a student, I am a mother, whatever. Personal traits, I'm an optimist, I'm an introvert, passions, I love nature, I'm a rider, or it could be relational roles,|||这并没有听起来那么难，但我发现做这件事最好的练习是我称之为“身份清单”的东西。它基本上只是要求你以一种你所不习惯的方式，真正地把聚光灯打在自己身上一秒钟。坐下来，写下10个短语、10个词，它们反映了你身份的不同部分。做一个清单。这些可以是正式角色。所以你可以说，在我的10个词中，我是一名老师、我是一名学生、我是一位母亲，诸如此类。个人特质：我是一个乐观主义者、我是一个内向的人；热情：我热爱大自然、我是一个骑手；或者它可以是关系角色，
I'm a friend, I'm a good daughter. Think of it as like listing the different hats that you wear on your everyday life, the parts of you that are going to show up in different situations, in different relationships and moves that all kind of come together to create your sense of self. some of these things can also be aspirational, things that you haven't quite achieved yet, but which you know will be in your future and that which, you know, you really want to have happened and that you're working towards. So, for example, I actually did my identity inventory the other day when I was writing this episode, and my list includes things like podcaster.
I'm a friend, I'm a good daughter. Think of it as like listing the different hats that you wear on your everyday life, the parts of you that are going to show up in different situations, in different relationships and moves that all kind of come together to create your sense of self. some of these things can also be aspirational, things that you haven't quite achieved yet, but which you know will be in your future and that which, you know, you really want to have happened and that you're working towards. So, for example, I actually did my identity inventory the other day when I was writing this episode, and my list includes things like podcaster.|||我是一个朋友、我是一个好女儿。把它想象成列出你在日常生活中戴的不同帽子，即你在不同情况下、在不同关系中会展现出来的你的那部分，所有这些结合在一起形成了你的自我意识。其中一些事情也可以是志向所在，是你尚未完全实现，但你知道它会出现在你的未来、并且你知道你非常渴望发生并正为之努力的事情。所以，例如，前几天我在写这一集时，我实际上做了我的身份清单，我的清单包括播客创作者之类的东西。
It includes things like writer, extrovert, explorer, empath, sister. and when I write these words down, yes, they might just be words, but all together, they create kind of a unique, a unique vision, a unique kind of, I don't know, a unique board, a unique mood board, I guess, splattering of who I am that makes it easier to live that truth. You know, for example, sometimes I feel kind of distanced from the creative side of me, but I know when I'm not doing something creative, I feel less like myself. And so having that word on this list forces me to basically acknowledge like, hey, if this is how I see myself, I also have to actively express this and I have to actively work on this side of me.
It includes things like writer, extrovert, explorer, empath, sister. and when I write these words down, yes, they might just be words, but all together, they create kind of a unique, a unique vision, a unique kind of, I don't know, a unique board, a unique mood board, I guess, splattering of who I am that makes it easier to live that truth. You know, for example, sometimes I feel kind of distanced from the creative side of me, but I know when I'm not doing something creative, I feel less like myself. And so having that word on this list forces me to basically acknowledge like, hey, if this is how I see myself, I also have to actively express this and I have to actively work on this side of me.|||它包括作家、外向者、探险家、共情者、姐姐。当我写下这些词时，是的，它们可能只是词语，但它们组合在一起，创造了一种独特的、独特的愿景、一种独特的，我不知道，一个独特的看板，一个独特的情绪看板，我猜，这是对“我是谁”的一种泼墨展现，让我更容易活出那个真相。你知道，例如，有时我觉得自己离创造力那一面有点远，但我知道当我没有在做创造性的事情时，我感觉自己更不像自己了。因此，把这个词列在清单上，基本上迫使我承认：嘿，如果这就是我看待自己的方式，我也必须积极地表达这一点，我必须积极地致力于我这一侧的发展。
Your identity is not just made of words, although there are words on this list. It's made of actions. It's made of doing. It's made of behaviors. at your center, how do you see yourself? Who are you? What parts of your identity feel valuable to you? What are you neglecting?
Your identity is not just made of words, although there are words on this list. It's made of actions. It's made of doing. It's made of behaviors. at your center, how do you see yourself? Who are you? What parts of your identity feel valuable to you? What are you neglecting?|||你的身份不仅仅是由文字组成的，尽管这份清单上有文字。它是由行动组成的。它是由实践组成的。它是由行为组成的。在你的内心深处，你是如何看待自己的？你是谁？你身份的哪些部分对你来说是有价值的？你在忽视什么？
How can you act in a way that aligns the part of you that feel important more towards yourself and that distances you from the behaviors that perhaps aren't reflecting this core inventory of pillars or, I guess, the core foundation of how you see yourself? Secondly, as important as it is to, of course, identify what areas you need to love more or need to prioritize more, it's also important to identify the things that you are doing just because you feel like you have to do them. These small choices chip away at our sense of self day after day if we're not careful. It is so easy to say, okay, well, I'll say yes to this thing at work because no one else will, or I'll do this kind of exercise because it's apparently good for me. Or, you know, I'll hang out with this person even though I really don't enjoy that company
How can you act in a way that aligns the part of you that feel important more towards yourself and that distances you from the behaviors that perhaps aren't reflecting this core inventory of pillars or, I guess, the core foundation of how you see yourself? Secondly, as important as it is to, of course, identify what areas you need to love more or need to prioritize more, it's also important to identify the things that you are doing just because you feel like you have to do them. These small choices chip away at our sense of self day after day if we're not careful. It is so easy to say, okay, well, I'll say yes to this thing at work because no one else will, or I'll do this kind of exercise because it's apparently good for me. Or, you know, I'll hang out with this person even though I really don't enjoy that company|||你该如何采取行动，使那些你觉得重要的部分更多地与自我对齐，并使你远离那些可能没有反映出这一核心支柱清单——或者我想，也就是你如何看待自己的核心基础——的行为？其次，正如明确你需要更多爱或需要优先考虑哪些领域非常重要一样，明确那些你仅仅因为“觉得自己不得不做”而去做的事情同样重要。如果我们不小心，这些微小的选择会日复一日地侵蚀我们的自我意识。我们太容易说：好吧，我会答应工作中的这件事，因为没有其他人会做；或者我会做这种锻炼，因为这显然对我有好处。或者，你知道的，我会和这个人一起出去玩，尽管我其实并不喜欢那家公司
because I feel a sense of loyalty and I should. I'll post on LinkedIn or social media because that's what I should be doing. Doing things purely out of obligation rather than out of an actual sense of choice and a desire to do them is a subtle form of self-abandonment that over time, accumulates and means that you feel more and more disconnected from that compass that should be at the center. When we repeatedly act out of shoulds rather than genuine desire or personal values, our sense of autonomy is very quickly eroded. This disconnect between what we do and what we want to do and who we are, I guess, it's what psychologists call incongruence. It's a
because I feel a sense of loyalty and I should. I'll post on LinkedIn or social media because that's what I should be doing. Doing things purely out of obligation rather than out of an actual sense of choice and a desire to do them is a subtle form of self-abandonment that over time, accumulates and means that you feel more and more disconnected from that compass that should be at the center. When we repeatedly act out of shoulds rather than genuine desire or personal values, our sense of autonomy is very quickly eroded. This disconnect between what we do and what we want to do and who we are, I guess, it's what psychologists call incongruence. It's a|||因为我有一种忠诚感，而且我应该这么做。我会发领英或社交媒体，因为那是我应该做的。纯粹出于义务而不是出于真实的自主选择和行动愿望去做事情，是一种潜移默化的自我放弃，随着时间的推移，这种放弃会累积，意味着你与本应处于中心的那个指南针越来越脱节。当我们一次又一次地出于“应该”而不是真实的愿望或个人价值观采取行动时，我们的自主感就会迅速被侵蚀。我们所做的、我们想做的以及我们是谁之间的这种脱节，我想，这就是心理学家所说的不一致。这是一个
mismatch between the self we project and our true self. Carl Rogers suggested, he's a very famous psychologist, you've probably heard me mentioned him before, he was the one who suggested that this incongruence is what creates a great deal of psychological distress in the modern day human. There was a 2016 study in the journal Motivation and Emotion, and it found that when participants were given the opportunity to do something. they wanted to, the way they wanted to do it, versus doing something out of pressure or guilt, of course, naturally, they reported being overall more happy at the end of the experiment
mismatch between the self we project and our true self. Carl Rogers suggested, he's a very famous psychologist, you've probably heard me mention him before, he was the one who suggested that this incongruence is what creates a great deal of psychological distress in the modern day human. There was a 2016 study in the journal Motivation and Emotion, and it found that when participants were given the opportunity to do something. they wanted to, the way they wanted to do it, versus doing something out of pressure or guilt, of course, naturally, they reported being overall more happy at the end of the experiment|||我们投射出的自我与真实自我之间的不匹配。卡尔·罗杰斯提出——他是一位非常著名的心理学家，你可能听我以前提到过他——正是他提出，这种不一致给现代人带来了巨大的心理困扰。《动机与情绪》杂志2016年的一项研究发现，当参与者有机会去做他们想做的事、以他们想要的方式去做，而不是出于压力或内疚去做某事时，当然，很自然地，他们报告说在实验结束时整体上更快乐
when they had the choice to guide their own behavior versus those who were made to do something out of obligation. It wasn't just that they were less satisfied with their experience in the experiment, they were less satisfied about their life in general. A lot of them gave much much more pessimistic outlooks about their life, the life that existed beyond the lab, having done that experiment. So those choices, although they might feel quite, I don't know, innocent over time when you continuously do things that no longer serve you, you do risk becoming a bit of a stranger to yourself. I think it's also the right time to point out another central point here. Sometimes getting back to yourself isn't about adding more to your
when they had the choice to guide their own behavior versus those who were made to do something out of obligation. It wasn't just that they were less satisfied with their experience in the experiment, they were less satisfied about their life in general. A lot of them gave much much more pessimistic outlooks about their life, the life that existed beyond the lab, having done that experiment. So those choices, although they might feel quite, I don't know, innocent over time when you continuously do things that no longer serve you, you do risk becoming a bit of a stranger to yourself. I think it's also the right time to point out another central point here. Sometimes getting back to yourself isn't about adding more to your|||当他们有权选择引导自己的行为时，与那些被迫出于义务去做某事的人相比。他们不仅对实验中的体验不那么满意，对自己的生活也普遍不满意。许多人在做完那个实验后，对自己的生活——实验室之外的生活——给出了非常非常悲观的看法。所以这些选择，虽然它们可能感觉相当，我不知道，无辜，但随着时间的推移，当你不断做那些不再对你有益的事情时，你确实冒着让自己变得有点像陌生人的风险。我认为这也是指出另一个核心观点的好时机。有时回归自我并不意味着给你的
plate. It isn't about adding more to your life, but thinking about what you can subtract. Imagine how much time we would have for ourselves if we were a bit more selfish and just said no more and we said, yes, only when we really wanted to. It's a wild thought for some of us, especially if you're a people pleaser, especially if you have a really ingrained sense of obligation to family or to friends, especially if you think that saying yes will make you more successful and saying no, we'll make you a pill to work with. But who benefits from you continuously saying yes when you don't want to? Who is getting something out of that? Because it's not you. It's someone else. It's other people. It's society at large, whatever you want to call it. But you
plate. It isn't about adding more to your life, but thinking about what you can subtract. Imagine how much time we would have for ourselves if we were a bit more selfish and just said no more and we said, yes, only when we really wanted to. It's a wild thought for some of us, especially if you're a people pleaser, especially if you have a really ingrained sense of obligation to family or to friends, especially if you think that saying yes will make you more successful and saying no, we'll make you a pill to work with. But who benefits from you continuously saying yes when you don't want to? Who is getting something out of that? Because it's not you. It's someone else. It's other people. It's society at large, whatever you want to call it. But you|||生活加码。这不是关于给你的生活增加更多东西，而是思考你能减掉什么。想象一下，如果我们自私一点，不再说“好”，只在我们真正想的时候才说“好”，我们会为自己腾出多少时间。对于我们中的一些人来说，这是一个很大胆的想法，特别是如果你是一个取悦他人的人，特别是如果你对家庭或朋友有着根深蒂固的义务感，特别是如果你认为说是会让你更成功而说不则会让你难以合作。但是当你不想说的时候却不断说好，谁从中受益了？谁从中学到了东西？因为不是你。是别人。是其他人。是大社会，随便你怎么称呼它。但是你
are not being served by that decision. My third tip for us today is more of a daily exercise and it's one that I personally do. I have spoken about it on the podcast before. In your journey back to yourself, it is so valuable to set intentions for your day every single day that relate to what you want to get out of that next 24 hours. Let me explain the premise behind this. So recently you may have seen a TikTok of a girl who basically said that every day the moment she wakes up, she asks the universe, show me how good it can get. Show me how good it can be. And when she does that, she reports almost every day at the end of the day, she reflects back and she's had like the most amazing 24 hours. The reason why is that your thoughts about your situation
are not being served by that decision. My third tip for us today is more of a daily exercise and it's one that I personally do. I have spoken about it on the podcast before. In your journey back to yourself, it is so valuable to set intentions for your day every single day that relate to what you want to get out of that next 24 hours. Let me explain the premise behind this. So recently you may have seen a TikTok of a girl who basically said that every day the moment she wakes up, she asks the universe, show me how good it can get. Show me how good it can be. And when she does that, she reports almost every day at the end of the day, she reflects back and she's had like the most amazing 24 hours. The reason why is that your thoughts about your situation|||并没有从那个决定中受益。今天给大家的第三个建议更多是一个日常练习，这也是我个人在做的事情。我以前在播客里提到过它。在你回归自我的旅程中，每天为自己的一天设定意图——与你想从接下来的24小时中获得什么有关——是极其有价值的。让我解释一下这背后的前提。最近你可能在TikTok上看到过一个女孩，她基本上说每天一醒来，她就会问宇宙：“向我展示生活能有多美好。向我展示它能有多好。”当她这样做时，她报告说几乎每天在结束时，她回顾过去，发现自己度过了最美妙的 24 小时。原因在于你对自身处境的想法
and your life shape how you view opportunities, how you view good days, how you view bad days. They shape how you behave, which in terms of. shapes your reality. We can do this same exercise, this same thing, to reconnect with ourselves by setting self-directed intentions. Like, today I'm going to go only where I feel I can find joy. Today, I'm going to really listen to myself. Today, I'm going to say no more than I say yes.
and your life shape how you view opportunities, how you view good days, how you view bad days. They shape how you behave, which in terms of. shapes your reality. We can do this same exercise, this same thing, to reconnect with ourselves by setting self-directed intentions. Like, today I'm going to go only where I feel I can find joy. Today, I'm going to really listen to yourself. Today, I'm going to say no more than I say yes.|||和生活决定了你如何看待机会，如何看待美好的一天，如何看待糟糕的一天。它们决定了你的行为方式，而这又反过来塑造了你的现实。我们可以通过设定自我导向的意图来做同样的练习、同样的事情，从而重新与自我建立联系。比如，今天我只去那些我觉得能找到快乐的地方。今天，我要真正倾听内心的声音。今天，我说“不”的次数要多于说“好”。
Today, I'm going to let the universe show me where I need to be. I know I'm going to have a great day. I'm going to be excited by life. Today is going to be excellent. I'm going to feel amazing. Those are just some examples of those affirmations or intentions that you can set. Psychologically, this also taps into a concept called priming. This is the idea that what we focus on, especially when our mood is really malleable, like at the start of the day, that can shape how we interpret.
Today, I'm going to let the universe show me where I need to be. I know I'm going to have a great day. I'm going to be excited by life. Today is going to be excellent. I'm going to feel amazing. Those are just some examples of those affirmations or intentions that you can set. Psychologically, this also taps into a concept called priming. This is the idea that what we focus on, especially when our mood is really malleable, like at the start of the day, that can shape how we interpret.|||今天，我要让宇宙指引我去我该去的地方。我知道我会度过美好的一天。我会对生活感到兴奋。今天会非常棒。我会感觉棒极了。这些只是你可以设定的那些肯定或意图的一些例子。从心理学上讲，这也触及了一个叫做“启动效应”（priming）的概念。这个概念认为，我们关注的事情，尤其是当我们的情绪非常具有可塑性时（比如一天开始的时候），会塑造我们如何解读
the world around us. Two people can be experiencing the exact same situations, but if one of them has an intention that they're going to only engage with things that align with them and the other person doesn't have an intention like that, how they finish the day is going to be very different. So basically, setting a daily intention shifts your cognitive filters. You don't see everything that sucks. You focus on the areas where you can expand. You focus on the areas where you can expand. You focus on the areas that you want to and the areas that make you feel good and that you make you feel more like yourself. So the world does start to reflect what you want to see and because you're being more intentional. You also get to be more in touch with what you actually want because that's the
the world around us. Two people can be experiencing the exact same situations, but if one of them has an intention that they're going to only engage with things that align with them and the other person doesn't have an intention like that, how they finish the day is going to be very different. So basically, setting a daily intention shifts your cognitive filters. You don't see everything that sucks. You focus on the areas where you can expand. You focus on the areas where you can expand. You focus on the areas that you want to and the areas that make you feel good and that you make you feel more like yourself. So the world does start to reflect what you want to see and because you're being more intentional. You also get to be more in touch with what you actually want because that's the|||我们周围的世界。两个人可能会经历完全相同的处境，但如果其中一个人带着“只接触与自己契合的事物”的意图，而另一个人没有这样的意图，他们一天结束时的感受将会截然不同。所以基本上，设定每日意图会改变你的认知过滤器。你不会把所有糟糕的事情尽收眼底。你会专注于你可以拓展的领域。你会专注于你可以拓展的领域。你会专注于你想要涉足的领域，专注于那些让你感觉良好、让你更像自己的领域。因此，世界确实开始反映出你想看到的东西，并且因为你更有意图性。你也更能接触到你真正想要的东西，因为那是
only way that you can actually express or set an intention is if you have a desire for a certain outcome in the first place, which as a consequence means you have to feel, you have to have better communication and be better able to listen to your internal desires. this is our starting point and i know all of these tips have been very i guess like thought based thought based exercises thought based activities enough of that we're done we're done with that we're done with the thinking component we're going to move on to the doing component we're going to move on to the fun side of this episode so if you want some practical things that you can do right now right at this moment in the next 24 hours and the next seven hours and the next seven
only way that you can actually express or set an intention is if you have a desire for a certain outcome in the first place, which as a consequence means you have to feel, you have to have better communication and be better able to listen to your internal desires. this is our starting point and i know all of these tips have been very i guess like thought based thought based exercises thought based activities enough of that we're done we're done with that we're done with the thinking component we're going to move on to the doing component we're going to move on to the fun side of this episode so if you want some practical things that you can do right now right at this moment in the next 24 hours and the next seven hours and the next seven|||表达或设定意图的唯一途径——前提是你首先对某个结果有着渴望，这随之意味着你必须去感受、你必须进行更好的沟通并能够更好地倾听你内心的渴望。这就是我们的起点，我知道所有这些建议都非常——我想说——基于思考，基于思考的练习，基于思考的活动。够了，我们受够了，我们不再纠结于思考部分，我们要进入行动部分，我们要进入这一集的有趣部分。所以如果你想要一些切实可行的事情，你现在就可以做，就在此时此刻，在接下来的24小时、接下来的7个小时、接下来的7
dates that aren't going to feel like a chore. Stay with us. We're going to talk about all of that and so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to live. look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
dates that aren't going to feel like a chore. Stay with us. We're going to talk about all of that and so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to live. look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.|||天内做那些不会感觉像是一种负担的事情。请继续收听。短暂休息后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%.这就是在有自动扶梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，去超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油天生具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Prescent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。经历一些艰难困苦，你会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 T-W-O-P-Ercent。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时代，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈 80 年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，但让你们知道一下。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在盲目追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要，还是你当好人是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是想做一个好人。加入我的节目，我是基尔·盖恩斯，
is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023 年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detection.
发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了她言辞中的明显矛盾。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吧？我篡改过一次测试结果。这需要一支网络侦探大队
detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Naranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
侦探们来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳兰吉尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura O'Brien. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So there is this common saying, perhaps you've heard of it.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·奥布莱恩。欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以有一个常见的说法，也许你听说过。
How you spend your days is how you will spend your life. How you spend your days will also determine how you feel about yourself. spend your days, I don't know, glued to your phone, or, you know, your weekends kind of doing the same thing, you're going to feel very one-dimensional because all you're doing is passively consuming or passively kind of following a routine that was laid out for you. If you spend that same time making things, exploring, pursuing goals, looking up at the world, I guess, therefore you, as a part of the world, is going to be. to feel more expansive and, well, I guess just rich, rich in experience. It's not just thinking
你怎么度过每一天，就会怎么度过一生。你如何度过每一天也决定了你对自己的感觉。如果你把日子花在，我不知道，整天盯着手机，或者，你知道，周末也在做同样的事情，你会觉得自己非常单一，因为你所做的只是被动地消费，或者被动地遵循为你设定好的常规。如果你把同样的时间花在创造事物、探索、追求目标、仰望世界上面，我想，作为世界一部分的你，将会。感觉更加广阔，嗯，我猜也更加丰富，体验丰富。这不仅仅是思考
exercises that are going to get you back to yourself. Experiences are going to do the same for you as well. Starting with your weekends. Here's how I think a typical weekend goes for many of us. You know, Saturday, you sleep in. Maybe you see a friend. Then maybe you like go out drinking or like you do something in the evening. And then Sunday, you know, you're so tired from. the week before, understandably, and also maybe from the night before, that you don't really do anything. Maybe you, like, do some chores, then the Sunday scleries hit, and like, that's it. It's Monday again. Typically, it is the same stuff every weekend, and then it's over. No wonder we feel so disconnected, because you have nothing to actually connect to, nothing to look
能让你找回自我的练习。体验也会对你产生同样的效果。从你的周末开始。以下我认为许多人的典型周末是这样的。你知道，周六，你睡个懒觉。也许你见个朋友。然后也许你喜欢出去喝一杯，或者晚上做点什么。然后周天，你知道的，你太累了，因为。上一周的事情，这是可以理解的，而且可能也是因为前一天晚上玩得很晚，所以你实际上什么都没做。也许你，比如，做一些杂务，然后周日恐惧症就袭来了，就这样。又是周一了。通常，每个周末都是同样的事情，然后就结束了。难怪我们觉得如此与世隔绝，因为你没有什么真正可以联系的东西，没有什么值得期待的
forward to in your free time. So here is how you are going to reprogram your weekend. Firstly, you are going to choose one day of your weekend and it's going to be a should free day. No, I should do my chores. I should go to the gym. I should see this person. None of that. This day is for you. You are going to go where your feet want to go, where your heart wants to go.
在你的空闲时间里。所以，以下是你将如何重置你的周末。首先，你要从周末挑选一天，这一天将是一个“不带应该”的日子。不，我应该做家务。我应该去健身房。我应该去见这个人。没有这些。这一天是属于你的。你要去你的双脚想去的地方，去你的心想去的地方。
Your only should for that whole day is to get out of the house and do something that you normally wouldn't. That's it. Leave the house. experience something other than your day-to-day. That is your only should. The reason this is so important is because new and novel experiences that we feel intrinsically motivated to perform, stimulate the brain's reward centers and promote a sense of expansion, but also openness to new experiences.
那一整天，你唯一“应该”做的事情就是走出家门，做一些你平时不会做的事情。就是这样。离开房子。体验日常之外的事物。这就是你唯一“应该”做的事。之所以这么重要，是因为我们内心有动力去完成的新颖体验，能够刺激大脑的奖励中心，促进一种开阔感，同时也让我们对新体验保持开放的心态。
I think as well, you just give yourself the space to breathe and to be present in the moment that is perhaps not available to you when you're working, when you're stuck in like the monotony of the day-to-day, when you actually have an open perspective and an open mind towards your weekends and you want them to be expansive days for you, you have more opportunities for happiness and to feel joy and to feel like, hey, this is a good life and this is a good feeling. And when you feel that way, when you feel relaxed and open to new experiences,
我也认为，你只是给自己留出了呼吸的空间，活在当下的空间，这或许在你工作时、当你陷入日常生活的单调中时是无法获得的。当你对周末有一个开放的视角和开放的心态，并且希望它们成为让你眼界大开的日子时，你就有更多获得幸福、感受快乐的机会，感觉“嘿，这是一场美好的生活，这种感觉真好”。当你有了这种感觉，当你感到放松并对新体验敞开心扉时，
that also signals your nervous system that it's safe, All is calm, you relax for a second. And that's when you can really hear, like, the call of your true self better, when you're no longer in survival mode, when you're no longer kind of crowded out by urgency and busyness. Alongside this, I want you to create a bucket list. And yes, we have talked about this before. And you know why it's come up in a few episodes is because it is so darn important as an adult to have things to look forward to and to have ambitions that have.
这也向你的神经系统发出信号，表明它是安全的，一切都很平静，你可以放松一会儿。而正是在这个时候，当你不再处于生存模式，当你不再被紧迫感和忙碌感所拥挤时，你才能真正更好地听到你真实自我的呼唤。除此之外，我希望你创建一个愿望清单。是的，我们以前讨论过这个。你知道为什么它会在好几集中被提起吗？因为作为成年人，有值得期待的事情以及有以下抱负是如此的重要。
have absolutely no purpose other than that they make you happy. You know, remember when we were a kid and we would like make our summer bucket list and it would be like, have a sleepover, like make s'mores, go to the amusement park, lemonade stand. Like, we need to bring those back as people in our 20s and 30s and beyond. We need to bring back adventure. Also, it means that when you have one of those days of being like, I don't know what to do. I don't, like, I feel bored, but I want to do something. instead of just like wasting your time thinking about which fun thing to pick or trying to search up and find or seek out inspiration.
绝对没有任何目的，除了它们能让你快乐。你知道，还记得我们小时候会列出夏日愿望清单，上面会写着：举行睡衣派对，烤棉花糖，去游乐园，摆柠檬水摊。我们20多岁、30多岁及以后的人，需要把这些找回来。我们需要把冒险找回来。这也意味着，当你遇到那种“我不知道该做什么，我不知道，我觉得很无聊，但我又想做点什么”的日子时，
Like you have your list. You have your bucket list. You don't have to waste any time. You go out and you make new memories. And in those moments, you get to see yourself in different spaces, different environments, different situations. Learning kind of who you are on the job, I guess. One thing on my bucket list right now that I think. think I'm going to do when I'm in Chicago later this week is the 12-hour walk challenge.
而不是把时间浪费在思考该挑选哪件好玩的事情，或者试图去搜索、寻找或寻求灵感上。就像你拥有自己的清单一样。你有了愿望清单。你不需要浪费任何时间。你走出去，创造新的回忆。在那些时刻，你得以在不同的空间、不同的环境、不同的情况下看到自己。我猜，你会在实践中了解自己是谁。我现在愿望清单上的一件事，我想
Side quest here. I recently read this book. It is called actually very aptly the 12-hour walk. And in it, the author, he is a professional endurance athlete. He talks about this personal experiment that he thinks we should all do where when we are feeling disconnected from ourselves, when we are feeling a bit lost, you need to commit to walking for 12 hours straight, alone and in silence, with nothing about your thoughts through your city or through a city, wherever you are. And during this 12 hour period, you can stop as much as you want.
本周晚些时候我在芝加哥时我要去做，那就是 12 小时步行挑战。这里插入一个小任务。我最近读了这本书。书名非常贴切，叫《12 小时步行》。书中，作者是一位职业耐力运动员。他谈到了这个个人实验，他认为我们所有人都应该尝试：当我们感到与自己失去联系时，当我们感到有些迷失时，你需要承诺连续步行 12 小时，独自一人，在寂静中，脑子里除了穿过你的城市或某个城市的所思所想之外别无他物，无论你在哪里。在这 12 小时里，你可以随时停下来。
You can take breaks. You can sit down. You could literally walk for an hour and then like, sit in a park for the rest of the 11 hours. But you can't be on your phone. You can't listen to music. You have to just be with your thoughts. And obviously, yes, you can. sit for 11 hours. The idea is that you don't typically do that. He wants you to keep walking and keep moving forward. And he argues that this is a really easy way to reset, I guess, your spirit, because you have to face so many internal fears and doubts and be alone with your thoughts and notice more about the world that we are kind of unable to do on our day to day and in our day to day life. It's also just, again, an adventure. So people apparently like finish this walk.
你可以休息。你可以坐下来。你实际上可以走一个小时，然后在公园里坐上剩下的 11 个小时。但你不能玩手机。你不能听音乐。你必须只与你的思绪相伴。显然，是的，你可以。坐上 11 个小时。这个想法是你通常不会那样做。他希望你继续前行，不断向前。他认为这是一种非常简单的方法，可以重置，我猜，你的精神，因为你必须面对许多内心的恐惧和怀疑，独自面对你的思绪，并注意到更多我们日常生活中无法做到的世界。这其实也是一次冒险。所以人们显然完成了这次步行。
feeling like an immense sense of purpose, an immense sense of direction. It's apparently very profound. So I'm going to try it and I will report back. I think you should also try it if you're feeling that that's an inspiring idea to you. If you have any sense that that seems like something fun that you should do, you should do it. Obviously, the 12 hour walk is something that you have to do alone. But there are probably a lot of things on your bucket list that. would be better with other people. And yes, whilst spending time alone is vital for reconnecting
感觉有一种巨大的使命感，巨大的方向感。据说这非常深刻。所以我要试一试，然后我会回来汇报。如果你觉得这是一个鼓舞人心的想法，我认为你也应该尝试一下。如果你觉得这似乎是一件好玩的事情，你应该去做。显然，12 小时步行是你必须一个人做的事情。但你的愿望清单上可能有很多事情。和别人一起做会更好。是的，虽然独处对于重新建立联系至关重要
with yourself, if you feel disconnected, please don't allow that to make you withdraw from your friends anymore or self-isolate. I get it when we feel bored, when we feel stuck in our lives, when our self-esteem is deflated. Sometimes the last thing you want to do is, is like have to conceal that actively from your friends. The last thing you want to do is be social. Social withdrawal is a very common coping mechanism when we're dealing with a sense of identity disruption or when we're not feeling like ourselves, often because it takes a lot of effort to be socially present, but also because we think more time alone automatically means more time to find ourselves. It's actually quite the opposite. It often results in a further exaggeration of depressive symptoms, a further exaggeration of
如果你感到与自己失联了，请不要让这种感觉让你进一步疏远朋友或自我隔离。我懂的，当我们感到无聊，当我们觉得生活陷入停滞，当我们自尊心受挫时。有时你最不想做的事情就是，在朋友面前积极地掩饰这一点。你最不想做的事就是社交。当我们面对身份认同感受挫或感觉不像自己时，社交退缩是一种非常普遍的应对机制，通常是因为保持社交活跃需要付出很多努力，也因为我们认为独处时间更多自动意味着有更多时间去寻找自我。其实恰恰相反。它往往会导致抑郁症状的进一步加剧，
loneliness, a further exaggeration of dissatisfaction. It's this weird behavior that does make us feel a little bit okay in the moment, but actually often ends up worsening our situation. Whilst I'm very aware that this urge can be very hard to fight, especially if it's connected with a mental health disorder, when you feel yourself slipping into this self-isolation social withdrawal pattern, I want you to remember the findings of this particular study. The study is from 2014 and it's titled mistakenly seeking solitude. And in it, these researchers looked at the experiences of over a thousand individuals who, when they were given the opportunity to engage with another person, were either encouraged to lean into the situation or they were told
孤独感的进一步加剧，不满情绪的进一步加剧。这是一种奇怪的行为，在当下确实能让我们感觉好一点，但实际上往往最终会恶化我们的处境。虽然我很清楚这种冲动很难克服，特别是当它与心理健康问题相关时，但当你发现自己陷入这种自我隔离、社交退缩的模式时，我希望你记住这项特定研究的发现。这项研究来自 2014 年，题为《错误地寻求独处》。在研究中，这些研究人员观察了一千多名个人的经历，当他们有机会与另一个人接触时，他们要么被鼓励投入这种情况，要么被告知
that they could do whatever they wanted to. So they could engage. or they could not engage. It was up to them, basically, in the second situation. What they found was that those who were encouraged to talk to someone, who were encouraged to sit with them, to engage with them, they reported much higher levels of connection, positive mood, and they left feeling happier, despite the fact that initially a lot of them thought it was going to be a hassle. A lot of them didn't actually want to engage with this other person in front of them. They thought it was going to make their mood worse. The opposite was the case. Interacting with others, even if it feels like it's going to be agitating, often ends up making us feel better. So if you want to feel
他们可以做任何他们想做的事。所以他们可以参与。或者他们可以不参与。基本上，在第二种情况下，这完全取决于他们。他们发现的是，那些被鼓励与人交谈、被鼓励坐在一起、与他们互动的人，报告了更高水平的连接感、积极的情绪，并且离开时感到更快乐，尽管事实上起初他们中的许多人认为这会是个麻烦。他们中的许多人实际上并不想与眼前的这个人互动。他们以为这会让他们的情绪变得更糟糕。事实恰好相反。与他人互动，即使感觉可能会让人烦躁，往往最终也会让我们感觉更好。所以如果你想感受到
more aligned, it is time to start seeing your friends again. It is time to start planning fun outings. It is time to know your neighbors. And if you really want to go one step further, if you have time, it's time to start volunteering. You really, like, if you feel disconnected to yourself, volunteering is a very easy way to get back to that version of you, who you respect and who you enjoy. This might sound controversial, but thinking about yourself all the time
更加和谐，是时候开始重新和朋友们见面了。是时候开始计划有趣的出行了。是时候去认识你的邻居了。如果你真的想更进一步，如果你有时间，是时候开始做志愿者了。真的，如果你觉得与自己失去了联系，做志愿者是一个非常简单的方法，能让你找回那个你尊重并欣赏的自己。这听起来可能很有争议，但一直想着自己
is probably making you like yourself a lot less. It's this thing called the self-absorption paradox. Higher levels of self-focus and self-awareness can actually increase levels of psychological distress. the more you try to connect with yourself, the more you try to investigate your behavior, the more time you spend with your thoughts and your thoughts alone, the less happy you're actually going to be. This is the situation that I found myself in last year. It spent so much time being like, all right, I'm just going to sit at home and I'm just going to think about my
可能会让你越来越不喜欢自己。这就是所谓的“自我吸收悖论”。更高水平的自我关注和自我觉察实际上会增加心理痛苦的水平。你越是试图与自己连接，你越是试图审视自己的行为，你花在你的思绪和独自胡思乱想上的时间越多，你实际上就会越不快乐。这就是我去年发现自己的处境。花了好长的时间在想：好吧，我要坐在家里，我要思考我的
situation and I'm just going to examine my behavior and if I think about it enough, I will come up with a reasonable explanation that will make this all go away. The moment that I decided to just Instead, direct that attention that I was putting on myself towards something and someone who needed me and that was bigger than me, the better I felt. For me, that was volunteering with animals. I started fostering dogs. I started doing rescue runs for local animal shelters where you basically fill your car full of dogs that dogs that are from kill shelters and you drive them across state lines or
处境，我要审视自己的行为，如果我想得够多，我就会想出一个合理的解释，把这一切都烟消云散。就在我决定不再这样，而是把放在自己身上的注意力转移到需要我的人和事上，做一些比我更伟大的事情时，我感觉好多了。对我来说，那是做动物志愿者。我开始寄养狗狗。我开始为当地的动物收容所做救援运送工作，你基本上把车里塞满了来自安乐死收容所的狗狗，然后把它们开车跨越州界，或者
to other areas that aren't kill shelters. and in those moments I felt more like myself than I had felt in a while because the focus wasn't on me. It was on someone who needed that attention more than I definitely did. Doing something for others. It's so important and it's so valuable and I think as a society, it's something that we often neglect, especially when we are, you know, told to be very individualistic and told to be very self-focused. But I know this is going to sound ironic.
送到其他不是安乐死收容所的地区。在那些时刻，我比以前任何时候都更觉得自己像自己，因为焦点不再是我。而是放在一个比我更需要这份关注的生命身上。为他人做点什么。这是如此重要，如此有价值，我认为作为一个社会，我们常常忽视这一点，尤其是当我们被灌输要非常个人主义、非常关注自我的时候。但我知道这听起来很讽刺。
For this final tip, I am actually going to redirect the attention back onto ourselves once more, despite that whole speech about, you know, doing more for others. I know it's ironic, but I do think that this final tip is equally important and bears mentioning. If you want to feel more like yourself again, you need to set a big goal for yourself. That has nothing to do with your professional identity, nothing to do with external validation, nothing to do with getting ahead or anything like that. What I mean to say is that it is important that each of us has some kind of a goal. Yes, we may have a broader goal that is very visible, but it's also important that we have a private goal
对于最后一个建议，尽管前面讲了那么多关于多为他人做事的宏论，但我实际上还是要把注意力重新引回到我们自己身上。我知道这很讽刺，但我确实认为最后一个建议同样重要，值得一提。如果你想再次找回自我，你需要为自己设定一个宏大的目标。这与你的职业身份无关，与外部认可无关，与出人头地或诸如此类的事情无关。我的意思是，我们每个人都有某种目标，这一点很重要。是的，我们可能有一个更广泛、非常显眼的目标，但同样重要的是，我们有一个私密的目标
that we want to accomplish, that we want to meaningfully work towards silently day in and day out. Setting a deeply personal, non-performative goal, one that is detached from social or professional approval, can really restore a fragmented sense of self because it engages you with your entreeves. intrinsic self. When we pursue something for the sheer joy of mastery or expression or the joy of the behavior, when we do that, we reestablish autonomy over our time, over our identity, over our actions. This is a form of autotelic behavior, which is basically a kind of behavior that engages with the flow of the behavior for its own sake. It's something that really nourishes our own internal compass. It's something that really allows us to understand what we want, what we care about,
我们想要去完成，我们想要日复一日、默默地为之有意义地努力。设定一个深刻的个人化、非表现性的目标，一个脱离了社交或职业认可的目标，可以真正恢复破碎的自我意识，因为它能让你与内在的自我建立联系。当我们纯粹为了掌握的快乐、表达的快乐或行为本身的快乐而去追求某事时，当我们这样做时，我们就重新确立了对自己时间、身份、行动的自主权。这是一种自成目的的行为，这基本上是一种为了行为本身的流动而投入的行为。这是真正滋养我们内心指南针的事情。这是真正让我们理解我们想要什么、我们关心什么的事情，
and it fosters something called self-integration. Basically, self-integration means that day by day, our behaviours align more with who we want to be until we feel like we are a more enlightened, higher version of ourselves. I think also the ultimate goal of this is that it builds trust in yourself as well. Often when we feel detached from who we are and we don't know who we are, we don't trust ourselves to get back there and we don't trust ourselves in general. We don't think that we are capable of achieving what we want to achieve. We don't think we're capable of getting back to ourselves. We don't trust that we can take care of this problem or any problem for that matter.
它培养了一种叫做“自我整合”的东西。基本上，自我整合意味着日复一日，我们的行为与我们想要成为的人越来越一致，直到我们觉得自己是一个更开明、更高阶的自我。我认为这的终极目标也是建立对自己的信任。通常，当我们觉得与自己脱节、不知道自己是谁时，我们不相信自己能回到那个状态，我们总体上也不相信自己。我们不认为自己有能力实现我们想要实现的目标。我们不认为自己有能力找回自我。我们不相信我们能够解决这个问题或任何相关的问题。
But when you set a goal and you work for it just invisibly, just in your own life, just for your own sake, you silently say to yourself, hey, we are able to go after things that we care about. we are able to achieve things that we care about. You can trust yourself. You can trust that you are going to be true to your word. Here are some examples because I know sometimes they're hard to think of. Writing a novel that no one knows you're working on. Training for a solo hiking trip.
但是，当你设定了一个目标，并为之默默努力，仅仅在自己的生活中，仅仅为了你自己的缘故，你在心里默默对自己说：嘿，我们有能力去追求我们关心的事情，我们有能力实现我们关心的事情。你可以信任自己。你可以相信自己会言出必行。这里有一些例子，因为我知道有时它们很难想到。写一本没人知道你在写的小说。为独自远足进行训练。
Growing like a balcony garden just from scratch just because you kind of want to. Creating art that you're never going to post anywhere. You're never going to sell. You're never going to put online. is another amazing one. These activities, you know, really connect us with ourselves and they bring our idea of our self, the one that we have in our mind, in line with how we're acting and how we're behaving.
仅仅因为你有点想，就从零开始在阳台上种个小花园。创作你永远不会发到任何地方、永远不会卖、永远不会放到网上的艺术品，这是另一个绝佳的例子。这些活动，你知道的，真正将我们与自己连接起来，并使我们的自我概念——我们脑海中的那个自我——与我们的行动和行为保持一致。
I think we could all benefit from a challenge as well. You know, when was the last time you challenge yourself? This right here, this moment where you're questioning a lot about who you are, is a great opportunity. Again, what do you have to lose? There's so much more that you can gain. and these new experiences are just a really amazing way to kind of find the path back to yourself, even if you are kind of blind for the first part of the journey, just doing things,
我想我们都可以从挑战中受益。你知道，你上一次挑战自己是什么时候？此时此刻，这个你对自己是谁产生了很多质疑的时刻，是一个绝佳的机会。再说一次，你有什么好失去的呢？你能收获的要多得多。这些新的体验只是寻找回归自我之路的一种非常奇妙的方式，即使你在旅程的前半段可能会感到有些迷茫，只要去做事情，
putting yourself in spaces where there is the opportunity for self-discovery, even if you feel a bit unsure, is really the only way to get through this. So as we wrap up this episode, I just want to say, yes, all these tips are important. I'm sure that they will be helpful. I hope they'll be helpful, but just have some great. with yourself, there are a lot of people in this with you. There are a lot of people in this world who feel very similar and don't know who they are because I think modern society and modern culture has made it very hard to spend time with ourselves and to spend time on our wants and our
把自己放在有机会自我发现的空间里，即使你觉得有点不确定，这确实是度过这一关的唯一方法。所以当我们结束这一集时，我只想说，是的，所有这些建议都很重要。我相信它们会有所帮助。我希望它们会有所帮助，但对自己好一点，有很多人和你一起经历这一切。世界上有很多人感觉非常相似，也不知道自己是谁，因为我认为现代社会和现代文化让人很难花时间陪伴自己，也很难把时间花在我们的愿望和
needs and not our shoulds. I think that's where this disconnect really comes from. We can't really hear the internal voice that's within all of us that is able to communicate with us and tell us what we want and we feel that emotionally and we're feeling that mentally and psychologically. So any kind of activity that just takes you out of what you think is expected from you or takes you out of your routine or a stagnant mindset and just into a new space of novelty, that is particularly luminous and it's particularly incredible and I really do think it will help you out. So I'm sending you a lot of love and a lot of empathy. I know how difficult it can be to not know who you are right now, but there is definitely a way back. Send this episode to someone else
需求上，而不是我们“应该”做的事情上。我认为这正是这种脱节真正产生的原因。我们无法真正听到我们每个人内心深处的那个声音，那个能够与我们沟通并告诉我们我们想要什么的声音，我们在情感上感受到了这一点，我们在精神和心理上也感受到了这一点。因此，任何能让你暂时脱离你认为别人对你的期望，或者让你脱离日常琐事或停滞不前的思维模式，带你进入一个充满新奇感的新空间的活动，都特别有启发性，也特别不可思议，我真的认为它会帮到你。所以我向你们发送许多爱和共情。我知道不知道自己现在是谁会有多困难，但一定有路可走。把这一集发给其他人
who you think might benefit from it if you yourself benefited from it. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast and leave the podcast a five-star review, whatever you are listening, particularly on Apple, if you want to leave, if you are listening on Apple and you want to leave a little review, those really, really benefit us and help the show grow and reach new people, especially if you feel like there was value in this episode or any others. Yeah, I very kindly ask that you consider it. Also, my book is still available and I will leave a link in the description. Make sure you check that out as well. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself and we will talk very, very soon.
如果你自己从中受益了，你认为可能会从中受益的人。确保在 Instagram 上关注我们 @that psychology podcast，并在你收听的任何地方给播客留个五星好评，尤其是在 Apple 上，如果你想留下一个小评价，那些真的对我们非常非常有帮助，并帮助节目成长并接触到新的人，特别是如果你觉得这一集或任何其他集有价值的话。是的，我非常恳请你考虑一下。另外，我的书仍在发售中，我会在描述中留下链接。确保你也去看看。但直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your... Podcasts.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取......播客的地方，搜索 TWO.%
On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。1979 年，对我和说对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并尝试通过我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何度过难关的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代那样。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you Get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师
and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world
兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号
that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023 年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德
was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini.
被指控让人生下双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吧？我篡改过一次测试结果。这需要一支网络侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。